so James do you think we should go over
the differences between bracket notation
dot notation and object literal notation
not really I think that conversation
would make this class a lot longer let's
put a link in the instructors notes to
give students more information good news
is they're pretty similar yeah that's
fair okay so we're about to get into
control flow in JavaScript but before we
do let's go ahead and finish all of our
objects the work object and projects
objects need to be created and let's go
ahead and finish up the biography and
education objects while we're at it
let's go ahead and clean out resume
builder js2 so that way it only contains
the four objects you might have some
code and resume builder J s from
previous quizzes if you want to keep it
that's totally cool but you should
comment it out with two slashes these
two slashes at the beginning of any line
will comment out the rest of the line or
if you don't want to comment out your
code you can just simply cut and paste
all of it into a different file that's a
good idea
let's start the next lesson with a clean
file with just our biographical objects
click this box once you've created your
bio Work Projects and education objects
and either cleared out or commented out
all of your previous code